há
[Música]
um ano era 2008 fim de ano dezembro
época de Natal
ceia peru farofa aquela coisa toda aqui
todo mundo passa a minha mãe
procrastinadora a família inteira como
sempre deixou para ir no mercado no dia
vinte e três de dezembro e falou vamos
comigo falei Óbvio vamos vamos no nosso
prêmio ano 86 Vocês já viram prêmio é um
carro gente hoje em dia ele anda meio
sumido mas é um carro é um carro é um
mundo daqueles quadradinhos sem bunda e
ele era um prêmio Verde bom fomos no
nosso carro Chegamos no mercado descemos
enquanto se passamos horas lá dentro
fazendo compra porque que elas filas
quilométricas começou uma chuva mais uma
chuva daquelas típicas de dezembro e
aquela chuva choveu choveu choveu a
gente ainda lá dentro do mercado saímos
tranquilos colocamos compras no carro
voltávamos para casa quando de repente
nos deparamos com uma possa imensa
os carros normais passavam
tranquilamente pela posta welinne mas o
prêmio não era um carro normal mais ou
menos ele não era a prova d'água cada
vez que ele passava numa poça algumas
vezes ele passava ileso e outras Ele
parava molhavam tal de distribuidor e
ele ficava aí parar o distribuidor não
secasse só que estávamos no meio da
Avenida então não tínhamos opção
tínhamos que passar não poderia ficar
ali parado
entregamos para sorte fomos quando a
gente tava no meio da Poça como era
esperado o prêmio parou nesse momento
que o prêmio parou eu fiquei muito
nervosa muito brava porque não era a
primeira vez que aquilo acontecia E aí
eu comecei bater no volante falar que
raiva desse carro não quero mais esse
carro queria ter um carro que prestasse
queria que sair dessa vida enquanto eu
tava ali reclamando e batendo no volante
passou um carro e me deu um banho de
lama de água de tudo que vocês
imaginarem molhou meu cabelo minha roupa
o carro meu rosto molhou tudo eu que já
estava nervosa fiquei ainda mais nervosa
e comecei a chorar ainda mais e aí eu
chorava batia chorava a cia e minha mãe
falava para mim Aline enquanto fecha
logo esse vidro antes que você tomou
para o banho e aí eu chorando e fechando
o vidro antes que eu tomava outro banho
mas aí nesse momento já me acalmei um
pouco e falei para ela eu não quero mais
ter que passar por isso
essa é uma dentre outras várias
histórias que eu pensava que eu não
queria mais passar por aquilo eu
desejava do fundo da alma não ter mais
que passar por aquilo por exemplo eu não
gostaria mais de ter que ver a minha mãe
trabalhando em dois empregos eu não
queria mais ver o meu pai pegando
lavagem para tratar de porco eu não
queria mais ter aqui comer McDonald's
uma vez por ano Queria poder comer
McDonald's quando eu quisesse a minha
família como vocês podem perceber né por
essas pequenas histórias eu podia ficar
que horas falando outras histórias foi
uma família com muita dificuldade
financeira e eu digo que eu só tenho
noção é do tamanho da dificuldade que a
gente tinha hoje né que as coisas
melhoraram mas na época é a minha mãe
comprava um uma cartela de Diogo hrnt
aqueles que vem seis e ela dividia três
para mim três para o meu irmão e tinha
que durar um mes E era uma briga aquilo
né porque eu não queria pegar o do outro
e tinha que durar um mês aqueles três
iogurtes é eu morei numa casa que não
tinha piso ela só tinha naquela noite
avisa ela só tinha cimento até os aos 23
anos de idade né na verdade quando eu
mudei para essa casa com seis anos ela
não tinha nem vidro nas nas portas que
eu via mais dentro do que fora mas enfim
então eram situações apesar da minha
família e essa dificuldade financeira a
gente era feliz né só que só dava se
conforto faltava eu eu ficava com muito
pesar de ver o meu pai e minha mãe
naquela naquela luta e a gente não eu e
meu irmão eles não conseguirem dar tudo
que eu e meu irmão que íamos é mas
éramos felizes mas antes nossos
problemas fossem só financeiro e eu digo
que às vezes esse é o menor dos nossos
problemas né A vida é muito criativa
Para Não Dizer muito dura e nos prega
peças
coisas pelas quais nós nunca imaginamos
passar e a primeira grande rasteira que
eu levei da vida foi a morte da minha
avó quando eu tinha 15 anos a morte da
minha vó mexeu muito comigo porque ela
morava com a gente então foi a primeira
vez que eu perdi alguém muito próximo e
ela cuidava de mim do meu irmão para
minha mãe trabalhar
Além disso teve outras passagens mas a
morte da minha avó me marcou bastante
porque como eu disse foi a primeira
grande tombo e nesses momentos assim
como no prêmio eu chorava chorava
chorava Mas eu sempre pensava tá bom Não
adianta eu ficar te chorando o que eu
posso fazer com isso agora e essas
histórias que eu tô contando eu não sou
uma pessoa especial
Com certeza que todos vocês já passaram
por alguma situação difícil na vida Pelo
menos nisso A vida é democrática
problemas todos temos uns maiores outros
menores sejam financeiros ou não mas
problemas todos temos mas o que eu
sempre tive para mim é que independente
do problema é que eu tivesse passando eu
sempre tinha
responsabilidade sobre a forma como agir
com esse problema por exemplo na morte
da minha avó eu não tinha o que fazer eu
só podia a rezar por ela e entender que
a vida era assim mas no caso da minha
dificuldade financeira Eu sabia que
aquilo poderia depender de mim então eu
acredito que temos
responsabilidades sobre a forma como nós
Agimos aos eventos que nos ocorrem seja
os que nós podemos mudar ou os que nós
não podemos mudar e eu acho que isso é
uma decisão trata-se de uma decisão
Olá seja um decisões para mudar as
coisas que você pode ou decisões para
lidar e aceitar as coisas com que você
não pode não tá um sol sob seu controle
né um exemplo disso eu penso se alguém
bate no seu carro Califórnia desde que
você não tenha feito barbeiragem Esteja
certo você não tem culpa mas a forma
como você desce do carro para negociar
com a pessoa o que vai ser feita a
partir dali já é responsabilidade
totalmente sua como você vai reagir a
esse evento Então essa coisa da decisão
eu acredito que ela tá inclusive ligada
a você decidir Onde você quer chegar os
sonhos que você quer realizar e como na
história do prêmio né Eu sempre pensava
o que que eu posso fazer para mudar essa
situação eu sempre gostei de estudar
então eu pensei a forma que eu vou
melhorar a minha vida financeira é
estudando porque é uma coisa que eu
gosto que eu sei fazer Ah e eu tinha
nessa época né Eu tava no ensino nao do
prêmio já tava no mestrado até mas nessa
época eu tava no que eu pensava isso eu
tava no ensino fundamental ainda e eu
pensei eu vou estudar na melhor escola
pública do ensino médio de São José do
Rio Preto que é a cidade onde eu nasci e
me criei que era at philadelpho Gouveia
Neto para entrar nessa escola eu
precisava passar no vestibulinho Quero
tipo um vestibular mas para entrar na
escola e eu estudei muito conseguir
provas na época não tinha recurso
internet nada conseguir provas antigas
estudei muito e passei só que engraçado
que antes de eu passar eu sempre passava
em frente lá do colégio e falava pegar
quem tivesse comigo onde eu ainda vou
ensinar nessa escola um dia que eu vou
estudar nessa escola eu tinha convicção
eu tinha certeza que eu ia conseguir
estudar lá por isso eu me dediquei tanto
e passei o mesmo aconteceu quando eu
entrei na UNESP de São José do Rio Preto
eu fiz matemática na Unesp antes de
entrar eu passar Oi gente dizia eu vou
estudar aqui eu vou estudar aqui eu
tinha uma certeza eu tema decisão que eu
ia estudar ele não nesp né porque também
eu não tinha como estudar em outro lugar
que era o único recurso que eu tinha mas
tinha ali universidade pública de
qualidade que eu sabia que eu poderia
mudar minha vida e assim foi a mesma
coisa quando eu entrei no mestrado a
antes de entrar no mestrado na verdade
já não nesta minha vida começou a
melhorar porque ali eu aprendi eu
comecei dar aulas particulares de
matemática eu fiz iniciação científica
Além disso eu trabalhava às vezes de
final de semana de promotora de vendas
eu já me virava então não ensino o
quando eu tava na graduação eu já podia
me dar ao Luxo de comer um McDonald's
por mês com o dinheirinho que eu ganhava
ali então ali eu vi que já tava fazendo
efeito Aquela minha dedicação por
estudar e por me esforçar e ainda
terminando a faculdade eu entrei para o
mestrado já ganhei uma o que era quase o
valor do salário da minha mãe
então acho que era na verdade a ser
igual e aquilo que já falei meu Deus né
isso eu tô estudando ainda e quando eu
estava no mestrado eu descobri que como
mestre eu poderia ser professora de
Universidade Federal ainda como mestre e
que eu ia ganhar um salário que seria
acho que duas ou três vezes maior que o
que minha mãe ganhava e quando eu vi
aquilo eu pensei meu Deus eu vou passar
e aí eu cheguei na minha orientadora do
mestrado e disse quando eu terminar o
mestrado eu vou virar professora de
Universidade Federal e já comecei até
falar para minha mãe porque como Rio
Preto não tinha pela minha família eu
falava gente eu vou ter que ir embora em
algum momento porque eu vou ser
professora de Universidade Federal e
aqui em Rio Preto não tem e todo mundo
ficava meio assim mas como assim você
vai embora favor não eu vou embora
porque vai ser onde vou conseguir
melhorar nossa vida e em 2011 eu entrei
aqui na uftm onde Sou professora até
hoje passei professora de Universidade
Federal me deixe é mas eu tinha certeza
que eu ia passar na verdade Parecemos
dois ou três concurso acho que esse aqui
foi o terceiro e eu passei né então eu
tinha certeza eu já tinha decidido
parece o tópico a gente pensar que tudo
que a gente deseja pode acontecer né Ah
então eu vou ficar aqui pensando eu vou
ganhar na mega-sena vou ganhar na
mega-sena e vai acontecer não gente né
não é assim na verdade mais ou menos eu
tenho uma tia que ela queria muito
ganhar na Tele Sena e ela passou uma
vida jogar na Tele Sena toda vez que a
gente ia visitar ela falava comigo meu
telefone para mim e quando ela tava no
fim da vida dela já Tadinha ela ganhou
r$ 5000 acho que não pagou nem toda Tele
Sena que ela jogou naquela comprou mas
ela ganhou não eu tô brincando né não é
sobre isso que eu tô falando não é sobre
esses desejos que depende do acaso do
aleatório eu tô falando sobre o desejo
que você tem no fundo da Alma né porque
também não adianta só querer todo mundo
quer correr uma maratona
Oi não quer falar inglês fluentemente
todo mundo quer ficar rico não é todo
mundo que é tudo isso mas a pergunta é
você tá disposto a pagar o preço que
você tem que pagar por exemplo para
conseguir correr uma maratona por isso
que eu falo que é sobre você desejar
algo do fundo da Alma
decidir e lutar muito até você conseguir
é você está disposto a pagar o preço por
esses objetivos né e eu acredito que é
só quando você deseja no fundo da Alma
que você consegue pagar o preço e não
desistir mas para não desistir Você vai
precisar de força de vontade porque eu
contando aqui parece que foi tudo muito
fácil mas não foi só eu sei o tanto que
eu tive que ralar para estudar para
conseguir chegar onde eu cheguei eu
passava Domingos de Domingos a Domingos
estudando quando as vezes amigos
parentes colegas estavam fazendo festa
se divertindo né quando eu já tava na
uftm eu decidi fazer doutorado eu
viajava mil Km por semana para conseguir
fazer doutorado passava a noite sem
dormir então é isso aí você tá disposto
a pagar o preço Então você precisa ter
força de vontade e eu falo dessa força
de vontade porque eu compro professora
também tenho o convívio com os meus
alunos e veja força de vontade e muito
bem e muitos deles eu fui professora de
um cursinho pré-vestibular para pessoas
carentes quando eu tava no mestrado e
ouvir agarra daqueles alunos eles sabiam
que a vida deles dependia de passar
naquele vestibular para melhorar então
eu via muito essa garra e também vejo as
vezes essa garra em alguns alunos meus
cotistas né eles se esforçam demais
porque eles sabem que aquele curso que
se eles terminarem aquela graduação bem
aquilo pode mudar a vida deles então eu
acho que esse desejo de mudar ele é
sustentado por essa força de vontade e
perseverança né nem sempre as coisas vão
dar certo de primeira bom além de ver
essas coisas nos meus alunos em mim né
Eu via isso muito no meu irmão também o
meu irmão ele ao contrário de mim ele
não gostava de estudar e ele não tinha o
menor talento para estudar também
então ele ajudava meu pai lá com os
porcos na roça né só que ele era uma
pessoa de muita garra também acordava 6
horas da manhã 5 horas da manhã
trabalhava do que precisasse de
tratorista então ele tinha muita garra
mas ele não gostava de estudar e quando
eu entrei aqui na uftm 2011 ele gostava
muito de cantar ele aprendeu a andar
sozinhos o caso violão sozinho ele
gostava muito e quando eu entrei aqui em
2011 ele resolveu que ele ia fazer uma
dupla sertaneja
arrumou um amigo dele lá que também
cantava e começar Essa dupla é então que
acontecia todos os finais de semana eu
vinha com meu carro e já era um Palio já
tínhamos melhorado eu saía com meu palio
a aba EA pressão José do Rio Preto
chegava lá sexta à noite sexta à tarde
ele colocava os equipamentos nesse carro
e ele fazia shows no final de semana e
no domingo ele me devolveu o carro e eu
voltava né Eu acho que é uma vantagem
dos meus pais também é que eles nunca
poderão nos nossos desejos nos nossos
sonhos se eles achavam que a gente tava
desejando do fundo da Alma que a gente
eles viram aquele brilho nos nossos
olhos ele sempre nos incentivaram mesmo
sem entender então que o meu irmão foi
da mesma forma e eu lembro que ainda
nessa época ele me disse Aline na época
Jorge e Mateus aquela dupla era muito
famosa e ele me disse Aline Um dia eu
ainda vou ser um cantor nós vamos ser
uma dupla de sucesso igual Jorge e
Mateus
confesso que eu achei ousada a meta dele
eu achava ele muito bom ele se dedicava
mas eu pensei em nossa né mas eu ele
tinha certeza daquilo ele tinha
convicção ele não sabia quanto tempo vai
demorar mas queria com a e ele ia e
realmente ele conseguiu para quem não
sabe o meu irmão é o Zé Neto da dupla Zé
Neto e Cristiano que é uma das duplas
que está mais no auge nos dias de hoje
então ele também conseguiu com esse
desejo e força de vontade Óbvio que não
foi fácil e a gente que tá de perto sabe
todos os percalços e a luta que ele teve
que fazer para conseguir chegar nisso né
E aí olhando todas essas essas histórias
e várias outras que não dá tempo de eu
contar aqui
empiricamente eu pensei que existem
quatro ingredientes para Conseguirmos
alcançar os nossos objetivos
empiricamente porque não fiz nenhum
estudo científico isso foi feito com
base na minha experiência a primeira
delas é o desejo você tem que desejar do
fundo da Alma olhar para sua alma e vê
lá no fundo que ela deseja a segunda
coisa é decisão uma vez identificado
esse desejo você tem que decidir que
você vai lutar bom né e a decisão também
de como você vai reagir às outras coisas
outros eventos que a vida te oferecer
Então você tem que decidir depois você
tem que ter força de vontade porque você
vai precisar se esforçar muito muito
mesmo até nos momentos mais difíceis e
por último perseverança
resiliência eu diria de não desistir
quando a coisa ficar muito difícil Aline
mas todo mundo consegue o que quiser
desse jeito depende porque você não
virou cantora Eu Jamais Seria cantora
porque não é um desejo do fundo da minha
alma mas se você ouvir lá no fundo da
sua alma eu tenho certeza que esses
ingredientes possibilitaram você
conquistar o que ela está te dizendo né
E aí